[Music]
man how many times am i going to play a
game as a bearded character voiced by
troy baker wandering through the woods
with a teenage girl who he's a father
figure for
after a million years since that preview
then what feels like no time at all
since that demo we now finally have our
hands-on
avengers was it worth the wait
i like parts of it i like that this is
the first game i've ever gotten an early
review code for
so i want to say thanks to square enix
for spotting me a copy and my good pal
james portis for helping me find a way
to put in the request for it
using some of his own personal
connections he's an awesome guy and you
should check out his streams
even though i got this game for free i
still feel it's my responsibility to
review it honestly and constructively
so i won't mince words about the parts i
take issue with but i'll be sure to
highlight the things that i like
because i feel like there's a good game
in here buried under
all the uh everything else
this is half a great game mentally
preparing myself to be called a shill by
the haters and call the hater by the
shills
god forbid an opinion have nuance
after so long in development with no
word on what the game would be
i feel like a lot of us started
imagining something really brilliant and
groundbreaking in our heads
but unfortunately avengers isn't that it
has little indications that somewhere
down the line
maybe it could have been but it's bogged
down by all this
open world microtransaction monetized
tedious character progression that'll go
on forever multiplayer focused bad
multiplayer generic objective one size
fits all play style
muck there's some parts of it that i
genuinely loved but a lot of it is
undermined by the live service elements
that keep bleeding
in these are the vip seats i can't see
[ __ ] from up here these are the
nosebleeds i want to be in that front
row
oh well all right that's cool i guess
the basic combat is very button-mashy
and reminds me of the olden days of
superhero beat-em-ups you've got your
light attack and your strong attack and
your super moves and
everyone has a projectile just like
ultimate alliance okay i can dig it
every character has their own unique set
of animations moves and combos but they
all play the same way when you boil it
down
a few days ago i saw someone tweet a
video of some captain america gameplay
where they were doing this sick combo
with tons of variation
but then i realized you don't have to do
that it doesn't offer any advantage over
just hammering the light attack button
then mexican some strong attack
the old square square triangle all of
this doesn't build up a combo meter or
do extra damage or
really anything except look cool i mean
it looks
super cool but i'd like if the game
actually like
incentivized you to do things like this
for more than
aesthetic purposes the combat feels
utilitarian and maybe a little
undercooked because it's missing that
really satisfying edge
like the increased speed and agility
batman gets with a long combo
or the tons of varied ways you can take
down opponents even quicker in
spider-man if you mix and match your
moves plus in spider-man
fancier moves and long combos also gave
you health so you're really incentivized
to not take damage and do the stylistic
stuff
both of those games had a really great
sense of rhythm to the fighting that
made it engaging
it was easy to get into a pattern where
you felt untouchable if you were skilled
enough
here avengers gives you this little
yellow circle as an indication marker
that you're about to be hit and should
dodge
but oftentimes the camera angle obscures
that because my character is always in
front of the enemy
but when i miss it and get tagged it
doesn't really affect anything except
doing a little damage
it doesn't break your momentum and force
you to slow down there is no momentum
the speed of the fight never increases
beyond just mashing until the enemy
falls down
the stun meter fills on individual
enemies instead of on your end so the
game pushes you to focus on
one guy at a time with a lot of
sequential attacks and it's really hard
to do anything flashy when you're being
ganged up on
because you'll typically get shot out of
the air by one of the other enemies
doing a move like this
the takedowns don't quite feel as
rewarding because you can't do them on
just anyone after building a really long
combo
it has to be on a single enemy you've
been focusing on this makes it way
harder to split your attention across
multiple enemies and you don't really
want to go for the takedowns unless it's
on like one of the really weak robots
ultimately i don't mind the combat nor
do i think it's even bad i just
feel like it's not very satisfying
compared to other superhero combat
systems
not bad but could be way better
a cool feature is that every hero has
their own special method of traversal
like iron man's flight
miss marvel's stretchy parkour hulk's
long jumps and climbing
and all the rest these are cool in
theory but clunky in practice
hulk's jumping and climbing is pretty
slow and stilted and doesn't feel as
good and fluid as like
ultimate destruction iron man and thor's
flight feel
really slow and limited you can just get
like
minor upgrades for your max speed i'm
disappointed because iron man's whole
gimmick is that he's piloting a skin
type fighter jet
but you never really feel that fast when
you're playing as him
there's also some other issues that
extend to all characters like
i present this as clear evidence that
qtes are outdated and we should stop
using them
because the options are something
awkward like this
[Music]
or this
maybe just start doing heavy rain or
telltale style ones where if you fail it
the consequence isn't death or
pausing you just kind of trip and feel
like a dork
i mean 90 of this games or incentives
are to look cool anyway so why not
oh you can just put the hammer on the
guy's chest and he's stuck that's cute i
like that this game has some issues with
texture load-ins that sort of take you
out of the moment during cut scenes
feels like i'm playing mass effect again
the whole thing just doesn't feel as
graphically polished as other stuff out
there right now
there are times when this still looks
and feels like a really high-end
ps3 game i don't mind it all that much
but i feel like some extra care on the
look of the game would have been really
appreciated
especially for the community who loves
photo mode art and photography stuff
this whole game is pretty buggy and
busted even after that 15 gigabyte day
one patch
[Music]
it needs a lot more fine tuning to iron
some of these bugs out that doesn't look
ready like games taking
10 to 15 minutes to load enemies
becoming invincible
t poses levels disappearing character
animations bugging out during cut scenes
subtitles and audio disappearing during
a cutscene with a major reveal in the
game
story
i've heard this particular cutscene was
broken for multiple people i know
again i recorded all of this after the
patch
speaking of mass effect i like how
everyone's got their own little room on
the helicarrier that you can access as
you gather up the team
reminded me of building up the crew on
the normandy and then exploring their
various personal spaces
there's also the mission select war
table that reminds me of the galaxy map
too
i wish this game was more like the good
parts of mass effect honestly
i'll tell you what no one online seemed
to be saying a few weeks ago
i love you [ __ ] but i didn't play that
so i didn't really have my perceptions
colored by my experience with that
i had my perceptions colored by free
early review code hell yeah in square
enix we
trust sure the game's combat felt a
little repetitive and button mashy but i
was used to that from pretty much every
older superhero game i've played not
every combat system can be batman
even though we went through that
annoying phase for a few years where
they certainly tried to be
it's enclosed in linear but i don't mind
there's still just enough exploration
for me and
really all you end up finding is new rib
cages for your high pressure dave and
bracelets for your fan girl
boss fight with abomination was pretty
fun it was cool seeing him again because
he hasn't really been in anything
substantial in like 12 years once the
movies were done with him
alright onto mission 4. oh
oh no everything i've played up to this
point was an extended three-hour long
tutorial
this is the real game isn't it
unfortunately that's exactly what
happened
oh it seems so much like destiny the
game that disappointed me in 2013 to the
point of turning me into the cynical
clone i am today
well at least i don't have to do
repetitive tasks like killing endlessly
spawning enemies while a monotone voiced
robot ai partner takes 10 minutes to
open a door or something
protect the uplink oh god i think i can
upload the protocols to a secure
oh god oh god in my initial run of the
game getting to this section felt like a
punch in the gut
it just completely sucked away my
excitement like a black hole of
games as a service and i turned it off
and went to bed
from here on out i started feeling the
game less and less
it started getting way harder to play
this game in single player because of
the amount of high level enemies they
throw at you
you have these annoying sections where
you have to stand in a circle for a
certain amount of time while getting
pelted with waves of robots and you lose
if you walk out of it for too long
and um yeah that's like the majority of
the gameplay here
that or smashing random sets of three or
four objects in the environment
rinse and repeat the objectives are just
so basic and repetitive and
mindless they all have to be built so
you can do these objectives
no matter which character you're playing
as but that inadvertently makes the
characters you play as
feel less special like any of them can
do the tasks so it doesn't matter which
one you choose
same [ __ ] different day your differences
are your greatest super power
there aren't missions where you'd have
an easier time playing as hulk over iron
man or vice versa so there's no strategy
to who you play as or
choose to be your companions you don't
build your team based on anyone's skills
or strengths or
stats or special moves it just doesn't
matter
let me make it clear i don't mean there
should be objectives that you can only
complete with a certain character or
roster because we all know how that
would go i just mean it would be nice if
choosing one character over another felt
like it would have an effect on
something
so everyone on the team could get a
sense that they had some special skill
or something to add okay so i don't
particularly care for this gameplay
model of walking around
open world areas that aren't actually
open world they're just slightly larger
linear areas
and then doing repetitive grinding tasks
to progress the story
i knew from the get-go that the
multiplayer and live service elements of
the game would irritate me
so i tried my best to ignore all of that
and just focus on the campaign
but it bleeds in and infects this
portion of the game too
nothing gets me less excited for a
game's progression than two things
a screen that looks like this or the
accursed word
gear being uttered
and yes i know the first one is kind of
silly because every
game has a skill tree like this now but
i still see these and then get
demoralized because i feel like the
gameplay isn't going to be smooth and
fun until i've unlocked the lion's share
of all these by grinding for several
dozen hours with half a combat system
then my greatest fear is that once i've
unlocked a decent amount of these and
the combat feels more complete
i'll be in the last hour of the game so
i won't get any time to appreciate it
normally that's not true but here well
there's
three pages of skill trees for every
character good god
it also doesn't help that these upgrades
are so expensive and time consuming to
unlock that you'll spend
hours doing it for one character when
you have another um
three four five characters to do it for
when we say we want the campaign to be
decently long to justify the 60 dollar
price point
we don't mean give us eight hours of
content but 40 hours of opportunities to
grind
the worst part is i would have been fine
with an eight-hour campaign
most games i like are pretty short
anyways and i have a social life and
jobs and other interests i don't really
need to play a game for 80 hours to feel
satisfied
and now i feel like i need to play it
for that long to grind for gear and
upgrades just to deal with the game's
random difficulty spikes in the few
hours of content it actually has
light rpg elements like adding gear come
into play here
like using certain gear to reduce damage
from some attacks or increase damage on
certain enemy types
that's all well and good and i
understand it but again
i feel intimidated by just how much of
it you get
the inventory fills up with all these
various gauntlets and chess pieces so
quickly that i get overwhelmed trying to
manage all this
it takes some of the fun out of it when
i have to sit down and read every single
item description in the list
weigh their ranks and which ones i can
afford to upgrade check the locker for
all the other stuff i picked up that
didn't make it into the inventory then
make sure i've done that for all four
types of gear
per character all just so i can play a
level that lasts 15 minutes where i
could have gotten through it anyway
without thinking about any of this stuff
no matter how much i fiddled with the
gear it just didn't feel like it was
having a big enough effect on the
gameplay to justify how much i was
micromanaging it
some would argue that the single player
stuff is muddled because the game's
focus is multiplayer so i figured i'd
give that a fair shake too
i played it with a few friends who all
have their own channels and are doing
their own videos on this game
go check them out because they're a bit
lesser known but make some really good
content
me and the fellows played this game's
multiplayer for seven hours and all came
to the same conclusion it's worthless
doesn't feel any different from single
player
like the only difference between this
and single player is that it feels like
your partner ai is improved and better
at combat
because it's a person but otherwise it's
all the same experience
one time i was doing a multiplayer
challenge with friends and all of our
reticules bugged out so we had to
complete the match without being able to
aim properly when throwing projectiles
targeting systems
like what's so groundbreaking and
special about this it's just
four guys beating up infinite waves of
robots we had that [ __ ] figured out in
2006.
try something else the characters
feeling unspecial is even more apparent
when you're doing things as a team
because the objectives are so basic and
bland that it feels like busy work
alright team let's go in and just
mindlessly fly towards the objective
marker
smash the thing and fly towards the next
objective marker
press the button and fly towards the
next objective marker go down the
elevator and we won
that's it it's a bad sign when the
characters feel better implemented for
co-op play
in the lego games than this look here's
a big heavy object that only hulk can
lift
here's a device only iron man can hack
here's a spot where black widow's
invisibility will help us infiltrate
here's a spot where cap's unbreakable
shield will come in handy
now these characters don't feel
interchangeable
even though their parts may be you have
all these big open environments but
nothing to do in any of them except go
to the objective marker and open the
same three chests full of gear in the
same
few spots forever things get even more
repetitive doing the combat challenges
in the harm room
you have a big holographic danger room
thing that could look like anything
but it only has one layout that never
changes and it's filled with endless
waves of the same generic robots you've
killed a million of
the enjoyment i got out of multiplayer
really wasn't from the game
it was just from hanging out with
friends that i enjoy talking to
the game was just keeping our hands busy
while we talked about stuff like it was
a podcast
and the micro transactions let's not
forget the glorious microtransactions
avengers spend game the wave of the
future
we'll sell you the car but you need to
pay extra for the tires windows and
radio alright gamers
i've avoided games with
microtransactions and in-game economies
like the plague for the past 10 years
it just didn't appeal to me so i wanted
to stay as far away from it as possible
and as such i'm a little behind on the
terminology believe it or not avengers
is the first game in quite a while that
i've played where i needed to think
about
any of this stuff so i may sound like a
blundering idiot trying to break all
this down
bear with me i'm trying my best here all
i play is horror games and ps2 [ __ ] i'm
gonna sound like an old man here
let's round them up you can pay money
for a thing called a challenge card
also known as a battle pass which is big
selection of random content you get by
leveling up
in-game by doing daily and weekly
challenges if you keep playing as much
as
possible you'll essentially get all the
money you spent on it back in equal
amounts of the game's currency but you
need to play a lot
there's 40 tiers and each one has a
different unlockable thingy you can skip
through the tiers by paying a little
extra
if you really want to unlock that [ __ ]
quicker without all the repetitive
grinding
everyone has their own battle pass
challenge card set of levels
and they're all free to start but for
any new characters added to the game in
the future
they'll cost 10 dollars even though the
character itself will be free
beyond that you can buy cosmetic stuff
by itself with some skins costing
upwards of 20
usd with a rotating store that
encourages impulse purchases before
they're gone
these systems are in place for longevity
so you keep dropping into play
every week and the game can remain a
service and a steady flow of income for
the developer
even after they've sold the pace game i
get that right i feel like i get
confused easily trying to understand
this stuff
so the more i buy the happier you get
correct and all these weird extra steps
and menus and hoops you have to jump
through to unlock
things is just so hard to keep track of
and care about
i shouldn't have to do a bunch of extra
research on blog posts like as a school
paper to understand this [ __ ]
i don't feel like i'm playing a video
game i feel like i'm trying to play the
stock market
though i've heard that the confusion and
complication is intentional so that
you'll just lose your patience and start
spending money on whatever
and that it's designed to be
manipulative i don't really know about
all that
i just know i won't play into it it
sucks that my experience with the game
is going to be a little more limited but
i don't want to get roped into buying
infinite amounts of currency or
impulse buying costumes for peer
pressure to look cool i don't want to
play all of these challenges because
they just don't really appeal to me
i just don't care about any of that plus
a lot of these skins
suck anyway they're just recolors of the
same three or four models
i learned my lesson from superhero squad
no one wants to play as scuba suit
batman with the flippers and oxygen tank
and no one wants to be a green and
purple recolor of superman
all of these skins are worthless and
ugly looking with a few rare exceptions
that actually do look like decent
modernized takes on the costumes
those are cool more of those please i'll
play this game but i don't want to spend
a dime on any of this stuff because it
just doesn't interest me
in all fairness though this game is
pretty light on the micro transactions
compared to some other stuff that's come
out recently
and it could be considerably worse but
it still could be considerably better
i think the practice is still just
irritating either way and i don't want
it to become the standard no matter how
lightly it's
implemented i have a feeling this was
supposed to have loot boxes but then
they scrapped it halfway through
development after seeing the battlefront
2
shitstorm i don't think
microtransactions are inherently evil
and i understand they're a good
additional source of income for some
developers
i especially understand when they're
implemented for like free mobile or
indie games because handing out a free
game wouldn't exactly pay the bills for
john the guy who has to model the
eyebrows on all the npcs to pay for his
daughter's ballet lessons
but this is a 60 dollar game based on
the biggest movie franchise of
all time published by one of the biggest
game companies out there
it's been proven a thousand times over
that a 60
game can sell well enough to turn a
hefty profit without monetizing the [ __ ]
out of unlockables so i have to ask
did this stuff need to be there did this
need to be a live service game couldn't
it have just been a fun four-player
co-op game with an emphasis on each
character being special individually
your differences are your greatest super
i would have been happy if this was like
a four man superhero version of a way
out
how it feels to chew five gum
there's big disgusting advertisement
costumes and content for wi-fi brands
mobile brands hardware manufacturers and
[ __ ]
gum brands cut remember in spider-man
when the game had
42 costumes and they were all free
all of these animations of spider-man
kicking ass didn't need to be purchased
or unlocked he just
did them you didn't need to buy anything
or grind a bunch of chuck e cheese
tokens to redeem them or
send in any cereal box tops you just had
to play all the stuff in the game
you had to find backpacks stuck to [ __ ]
remember how simple that was
all of them were individually rewarding
as a collectible because they had a neat
backstory that was tied to them
everyone was having a good time can we
bring that back remember when the
product placement was just
billboards in the city so it felt kind
of realistic instead of plastered on
your childhood hero's ass
i know i'm never touching one of those
i'd feel like captain amazing
is this your best look i know a thing or
two about having to advertise or plug
some products to make your bread
it's perfectly fine and you can bet the
first mountain dew i ever drank was just
so i could get the halo experience
points out of the bottle cap
whatever it's a fact of life like death
and taxes if you want to be in the
entertainment industry
art needs a little commerce to exist but
i feel like putting the advertisement on
the characters themselves is a step too
far because now
it doesn't feel like the game is
chilling for a product it feels like
captain america himself is and that's
gross to me i don't really appreciate
that no more of that
your unicorns just showed up what do you
think
what do you have against capitalism keep
the branding separate from the
characters at least
i know there's probably been a million
channels out there who have talked about
this stuff before in a more intelligent
way
subjects like predatory
microtransactions contributing to
gambling addictions
the way this stuff is legally dubious or
how it just feels insulting to the
customer
never really talked about that before
because like i said i just didn't really
touch any games where these things were
relevant because it's not my personal
interest
i think these practices of monetizing
the game as confusingly as possible and
pushing in sneaky tactics to trick
people into buying things is pretty lame
especially since you just know there are
kids playing this game
it's avengers mommy may i borrow your
wallet i don't want the silly robot to
be sad
i like short and sweet games with a good
story and skill based single player
games so maybe this one just isn't for
me on that level and it's unfortunate
that my love of superheroes has forced
me to be in proximity with this stuff
and break my otherwise clean record
if you're cool with games doing this
kind of stuff
that's fine too if you've got the money
to spend on it and it's fun for you then
whatever but it's not my cup of tea i
don't really get any enjoyment out of it
is that fair
put the pitchfork down timmy captain
carlos and captain jill are the best
avengers so what's left that really
makes this game not completely worthless
well the avengers themselves ironically
the story has a few issues
but it more than makes up for that in
heart and a clear love of these
characters and material
it's weird how many references there are
to avengers and spider-man only for
those two to end up not being connected
at all
west coast aim taskmaster
nothing okay so a few years back the guy
in charge of marvel tv
ike perlmutter who is famously a weirdo
racist said that he wanted to use the
x-men's mutants in
agents of shield despite not having the
rights instead he used his seniority as
a producer to force marvel studios to
give him the use of the inhumans to fill
the void of a marginalized superpowered
minority group which could make for
quick and convenient introductions for
various super-powered characters in the
tv shows you don't have to give
everyone a unique origin just make a big
explosion that gives
everyone powers just like the flash
just like static shock remember the big
bang
now he had his own legion of bang babies
to use in his shows at the cost of the
planned 2018 inhumans movie
and we all know how that turned out the
comics even briefly adjusted to match
this by having a random sample of the
population becoming humans while also
killing off as many of the mutants as
possible
gee tell us what you really think guys
but hey at least we got miss marvel and
synapse out of it
seems like this game took some cues from
that by having the terrigen crystal
explode at the beginning of the story
and turn a lot of random folks into bang
babies as a quick and easy explanation
for tons of super powered bosses and
street thugs
is it a lazy way to write superhero
world building
am i mad about it well yeah because they
didn't use any of them
kamala is like the only named
recognizable character to get powers out
of this
and everyone else is just default white
guy npcs with generic names
you spend the whole game fighting robots
instead of people with powers
so that feels like a huge missed
opportunity we're inhuman
no one cares about us and to be honest i
didn't really connect with the inhumans
a lot because we only get to know
one of them and i just default to
thinking of her more as
the rookie avenger than part of the
inhumans as a whole
they're more just a plot device than
anything no one cares about us
but it serves as good backstory for why
the world is in jeopardy and needs the
avengers to come back
after fumbling a super villain attack
during a public event and doing the
superhero equivalent of accidentally
saying a slur on wheel of fortune
the avengers disband because they feel
like they failed the world and let
captain america die
so they all mope around for five years
like that movie you saw no matter who
you are
until one day an excited young fan
decides to go on a cross-country road
trip to get the band back together
this is the plot of the country bears i
enjoy the framing of the story a lot
and it was a good idea to make kamala
our window an introduction into this
world because
she's the most normal and down to earth
character in the game she's just a
normal kid instead of a genius scientist
billionaire professional assassin or
time traveler
she's just as much of a fan of these
characters as we are so it's fun seeing
her geek out about the references in
easter eggs it's a smart idea to have
all the avengers meet and introduce
themselves to her
because then by proxy we the players are
getting introduced to this version of
the team
since they're all already established
it's like a better version of what they
tried to do with mcu spider-man
except kamala was always an obsessed
avengers fan so they didn't need to
change anything about her and make it
work
and it serves a clever purpose in
helping to establish the characters more
strongly
and i really love these characters
everyone on the team
feels very likable and charming and i
dig the voice cast
i was really worried about nolan north
and troy baker being iron man and hulk
respectively but after a while they
really grew on me and i stopped hearing
those voice actors and just started
hearing the characters
i think that's a real testament to their
ability as voice actors and i understand
why they're considered the best of the
best
the alternative was probably just a
bunch of awkward clunky
mcu actor impressions that would have
been far more distracting
after the avengers all decide to pursue
other projects and tony and bruce start
doing separate let's play channels
a scientist who is mutated by the
terrigen mist is now using the evil
corporation aim to take
over the world piece by piece and
capture all the inhumans because they're
a menace to society in x-men comics
everywhere
then he's a modoc why does he call
himself modok
it's never explained just roll with it a
lab tech named george comes to work one
day and he gets his head blown up like a
whoopee cushion
and then it's fused to a flying toilet
laughing yet
how about this one the best evil scheme
he ever came up with was figuring out
how to wipe himself with his stubby
little tyrannosaurus rex arms
eat a bag of stubby leg
i liked him better when he was bruce
campbell what i don't like about this
story
is how little it feels like anything
happens in the story
you're just going from aim base to aim
base smashing things and every few hours
another avenger jumps in and joins after
a single cut scene of convincing
then on to destroying more aim bases you
don't really feel like you're going
anywhere or exploring the marvel
universe because all the recognizable
landmarks have been turned
into the same generic sci-fi levels full
of multi-colored robots to smash
the environments that you explore are
really bland and basic
like forest desert snowy forest
snowier forest like four square blocks
of a city with nothing in it
etc this suffers from the same problem
as ultimate alliance where you're stuck
in metal corridors for a while
but that game had the advantage of
occasionally taking you somewhere really
cool and special that
was like a location from the books here
and not so much there's also a pretty
gross lack of villains for a game this
length
just more robots a few characters or
ideas are just randomly introduced or
dropped without a second thought
boy would have really made me care about
the plight of the inhumans if i saw this
guy reunited with his mother or whatever
but we'll just forget about that scene
you fight the watchdogs for like one
scene
and then they never talk about him again
abomination just walks in out of nowhere
appears in one more cut scene after you
beat him
then is gone forever modoc pulls this
giant robot out of nowhere and thor is
like
oh it's this thing i know those where
did it come from how did he find out
about it why is it there what's its
purpose
doesn't matter shut up here's more
scenes of the avengers being [ __ ]
cute
the lack of variety isn't helped by how
quickly this game ends
the story mode is so short that i have
this awful gut feeling that there will
be a 40
story dlc to show you how it really ends
[ __ ] you but all of these things are
negligible because at the very least
the story is an incomprehensible dribble
these linear levels full of scripted
events are ironically where i felt the
most free in the entire game
because i wasn't worrying about leveling
up or gear or boosting stats or finding
loot or cosmetics or whatever
i was just enjoying the story the game
was trying to tell and feeling connected
to these characters and the chemistry
they had during their odyssey these
characters
really hold it down and make you care i
didn't really give a [ __ ] about the
inhumans
but i cared about miss marvel and seeing
her interact with the team and develop
all these relationships with them as her
mentors and friends
was really special any time it's a cut
scene where these guys are all just
standing around talking
it's riveting they're so well acted and
so charismatic
this game really understood the avengers
individual personalities and at their
core
the team isn't the idealized legion of
perfect people the fans see them as
they can be immature unconfident
self-loathing
distrustful and a boomer they're all
very flawed and damaged people
who just want to do the right thing even
when they don't always know how to
even though they have a hard time
getting along at times it's because
they're a family
family of misfits but when they work
together
they can do anything even after
everything
i don't feel like this game as a whole
was a quick and easy cash grab
parts of it are very disappointingly
greedy or underwhelming
but i feel like at some point down the
line this game was made with a lot of
love and passion these linear levels
where you get to explore a character's
individual talents and see them
interacting with their super pals in a
creative and fun set piece
these are the real standouts like
captain america and iron man escaping an
exploding satellite
miss marvel running from the hulk after
he thinks she stole cap's shield
iron man exploring around his decaying
family home to build a makeshift suit
and gear up for action or the beginning
and end of the game where you play as
every avenger as they take on a unique
obstacle suited to their skills
parts like these are where i see this
game's untapped potential
this could have been a really amazing
single player experience if the game was
more of that stuff
but as it is it's unfortunately bogged
down by things i want to believe the
game wasn't originally intended to have
the live service elements and
multiplayer elements feel so
underdeveloped and tacked on i started
wondering if they were added later in
development and this game was probably
meant to be something more linear and
toned down
i feel like somewhere down the line
something changed and it lost its
identity but i wasn't part of
development so i can't say for sure
that's just speculation on my part
buried under all this unnecessary fluff
there was the makings of something
special with the end result being a
mixed bag that i think
had more potential and i hope that one
day we do
get the game that this one tried to be
because i have a feeling it came very
close to being something great
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you